Lynne is with us in Dallas Texas hi
Lynne how are you I'm great how are you
better than I deserve what's up thanks
for taking my call first we need some
advice on how how to handle a situation
with our daughter and son-in-law
they're both 27 she's once again
unemployed losing her third job in a
year
what is she losing um well she just
doesn't listen I can't get along with
the people can't follow instructions she
in a but is not working out for right
but hadn't quite connected to her yet
Josh
she's been employed 22 weeks out of the
last 61 but she does have a job that
begins August 1st and is drawing
unemployment until then neither of them
have made an attempt to get a part-time
job or to increase their income or cut
their expenses and quite honestly
they're insulted by the suggestion of
doing that we started early trying to
teach her money management but as you
can tell strong will do what I want
attitude followed through on that is
other areas in her life and I must say
that she doesn't come to us unless it's
an emergency
the last emergency situation though was
a call from her husband that she was in
jail he we learned then that she had a
minor car accident several months before
that to complicate it their insurance
had been cancelled several months before
that and her husband had not only not
told her but he hadn't gotten around to
getting a replacement insurance and then
she ignored the court date so she was
hauled off to jail so you can see the
trail here of your responsibilities so
after discussing the situation we told
her husband that we'd pay the thousand
dollars to get her out of jail if and
only if they'd agreed to some
accountability on getting their finances
in order and he agreed however a couple
of days later when I tried to set up the
meeting to discuss it
he sent me a text saying that he would
not talk with me that he'd he would give
me progress updates on their financial
situation as he chose and any further
discussion would be considered
harassment and dealt with his such okay
I can handle that I was able to meet
with them long enough to say okay if
you're not willing to you know a great
do what you agreed to do make a budget
and accountability don't be expecting us
to supply money for future emergencies
you're right you're wise there Wow
and then I was later told by his family
that he was very fragile emotionally and
I should not have done that yeah well
most potholes are and I don't see any
opportunity for discussion with them so
we could not understand how they were
living at the level they were with the
money they were making and her not
working most of the time but we found
out that his mom monitors his cash
account and puts money in on the
balances in the reg that's shocking how
she's paid off several credit cards
several times and cut them up on car
payment got the picture how can I help
today
okay I need support on what I mean we
feel I feel like I know what to do I
mean I've looked at your website we've
you know not drawn but you still feel
like such a you know had the guilt trip
and then to have his parents really his
mom mostly give you the guilt trip
double I guess I just need support on
and how to follow through with this on
okay what you've got here is his mom is
a complete but she's raised a but your
daughter's being a but yeah and if you
participate in this you are funding buts
I mean you just can't do this you just
can't I do I feel like such a bet you're
not you're not because you're the only
grown up in the whole conversation hmm
you're the only grown up in the whole
conversation you told me was harsh
nothing you told me was a controlling or
out are over the top or you were
interfering in their life it was all
acts of love and you've been you've been
not only told to stay away people have
been rude to you yeah yeah and that's
probably not all of it yeah and so you
know here's the deal we love you we're
praying for you if you guys want to eat
dinner come over we'll feed you dinner
we're not going to listen to you whine
about your life though and we're not
going to give you any money but we love
you good luck you know you remember that
part where you told me to stay away or
it would be harassment hmm I'm taking
that part now seriously I'm going to
stay away and and by the way when I stay
away my checkbook is with me mm-hmm
that's how that works no respect I don't
have to come very often because mom
supports them well that she'll run out
of that eventually because she's in
under how under well she will you know
it sure run out of money eventually what
what do we do run that's all you can
well even in the future like and on this
was no will I mean on our will I
wouldn't leave her he wouldn't know you
wouldn't leave on any no no I told my
kids if you're going to be a doofus I'm
not funding doofus because here's the
deal I don't know where you stand I'm a
person of faith I'm a Christian and God
has told me real clearly that in the end
the Scriptures that I am managing money
that he gave me for him and I'm supposed
to be a good manager there's a chance of
me putting your daughter in my will is
zero because I'm a good manager mm-hmm
and I've told my kids if you're doing
heroin or you know you decide you're
going to run off and live a life of
debauchery or not you're not walking
with the Lord I'm not going to I am
duty-bound by the Lord to not give you
his money and fund your misbehavior with
his money hm-hm I'm duty-bound as a
steward as a manager I have to and so
just understand you know if you're going
to run off and live a life a craziness
if you're going to be nasty and mean to
us then we're not going to be funding
your life now that can be changed while
I'm still alive you can grow a brain
grow a life come back together have some
character rebuild a relationship and
we'll put you back in the will but our
kids it's real clear they are entitled
to nothing because they happen to be
born of Dave and Sharon zero entitlement
zero because it's not my money I'm
managing and forgotten
it's not their money they'll be managing
it for him
and if they don't see it that way they
won't get any none zero mm-hmm I've been
real clear on that and we have a little
meeting once a year and over our state
plan and I you know we just that you
know our family has a family
Constitution at the top of the
Constitution as for me and my house we
will serve the Lord and it's not me
being mean I'm just being passionate
right now to inject into you because
you're getting you got so much stupid
around you that you need to hear
somebody's tell you you're smart yeah
and this out you know none of the things
if you read Henry Clouds book boundaries
when you're in when you're in the middle
of a situation where everyone you're in
contact with in a situation is violating
boundaries you begin to think you're
crazy mm-hmm and they are all their
travel agents for guilt trips I mean
they will sign you up for a guilt trip
all of them and you know I would tell
his mother never be again I really never
call me I don't talk to you well she
doesn't want to talk to me because I was
so abusive to the son yeah good don't
call me ever again I don't want to hear
any more information through you ever
hmm okay now when you wait when
everybody gets cleaned up I'll be the
last one I will reconcile with after I
get everybody else straightened up but
you're the problem of this you're the
root of all evil chick hmm you are you
are man she's bad news she is an enabler
from now on and so you need to get Henry
clouds book boundaries you need to read
it you are not crazy you are right and I
got to tell you it's a very sad
heartbreaking one of your kids as a but
your kids a but she's a she's a
world-class but and I wouldn't give her
anything this is the Dave Ramsey show
you